- It's still pretty kinda spicy.
Is that a thing?
Are millennials spicy?
Is that the flavor that we like?
- I love Diet Coke.
I might drink a can a day.
- Don't drink a lot of soda,
but when I do, it is Diet Coke, bar none.
- In high school, I would
drink Diet Coke every morning
at 8:00 AM.
- Me and my dad, we would
just drink Diet Coke.
- Such a cool bonding device.
- Cool device.
- We're Diet Coke fans, so
we know there's new flavors.
We just haven't gotten
them in our possession yet.
- [Director] So these
new Diet Coke flavors are
marketed for millennials.
What do you think of that?
- Are they light pink?
- Like millennial pink?
- I feel like I'm gonna like them
and I'm gonna be embarrassed
that I like them.
- I mean, if they taste
good, then I don't care
who they're marketed towards.
- LaCroix is like exploding everywhere,
so I think it makes sense
that they want to branch out
to flavored Coke.
- Everyone's marketing
towards millennials.
I don't know why because
we have no money at all.
- What about it is millennial like?
Is it gonna be like Instagram?
What does that mean?
- Let's try the new flavors.
Jinx, you owe me a soda.
- Nice one, nice.
Okay, this one smells very strong.
- Smells orange-y.
- Maybe it's like an orange citrus.
- Cheers.
- This is really hard to determine.
- I'm pleasantly surprised.
- Love that, I really do.
- You still taste that
faint blood orange-y taste,
and it's like perfect,
still Coke-y, that's a word.
- It's just like too vague.
Maybe if they committed to
the flavor a little more.
- It could mix well with
vodka or a citrus-y vodka.
- These are made to be mixed
with alcohol for some reason.
Is that the millennial?
I'm just here to figure out
why this is for millennials.
- This just smells like
straight Diet Coke.
- Smells like Diet Coke.
- It smells like slightly
vanilla-ish potentially.
- I love vanilla.
- I think this is the ginger one.
- So this one smells like ginger ale,
which I'm also not mad about
because ginger ale's great.
- Is it just me or are all of these spicy?
- Or it might be like a lime.
- It's definitely
- Ginger lime.
- Ginger something.
- It's ginger lime, so
we're actually both right.
- Yeah, it really doesn't
taste like Diet Coke,
which could be a good thing
for people who don't like it.
- I feel like these are a little too light
with the flavoring, but I like this combo.
- I 100% think it's millennial.
- Yeah, isn't ginger supposed
to be like a health benefit
thing or something?
- So I did a detox
that I couldn't shut up about for a while.
- Wafts it.
- Wafting.
- I feel like I'm at a wine tasting.
This is definitely black cherry.
- I'm getting a hint of fruit.
- Ooh, grape?
- I'm getting a hint of
millennial verified on Instagram.
- Cheers.
- I get a cherry feeling.
- That tastes like regular Diet Coke.
- It's like really,
really weak black cherry.
- Should I gargle it?
- Yeah, I dig it.
- Because it just tastes kinda normal
with like a little bit of kick at the end.
- I was not gonna say
yes to that question.
- Are we guessing or
are you telling us what?
- Feisty cherry.
- Oh, okay.
- Honestly, I was
really close.
- Feisty cherry.
- Feisty indeed.
The moment you open this
can, you take a whiff,
the smell's there.
- It tastes like a spicy cherry.
- This looks like a little spritzer can.
- I like the branding.
- There was Cherry Coke
in the past, right?
- I feel like we've had
Cherry Coke for a while.
- There is Cherry Coke.
There is Cherry Coke now, I think.
- Oh, this has distinct something.
I also have a bad sense of smell.
- Whoa.
- Whoa, that's strong.
- This is strong.
- I want to say melon.
- It's like a candy but I can't tell.
- It's passionfruit-y.
- It's like millennial bloodhound.
It's mango.
- I feel like it tastes like a candy.
- It's a fruit rollup.
- This would go good with coconut rum.
- This is really good.
I don't know where
mango became so popular,
but we made it hot, just saying.
- I'm perplexed by this one.
- Mango.
- I love their adjectives.
- This reminds me of freshman
year at UMass, I can't.
- Definitely my number one.
- Very millennial.
- I was just making an
Instagrammable photo there.
- [Director] We're not
Instagramming right now.
- Okay, Diet Coke number one.
- Number one.
- I would say mango.
- Okay, mango is definitely
number one.
- I like the orange one a lot.
- Stick to the basics.
And then ginger lime.
- Orange or cherry could be number two.
- I like the Feisty Cherry second.
Yeah, you agree? Okay.
- This is our lineup.
- Lock it in, final answer.
- Part of their millennial advertising,
they're like millennials,
they've seen lemon.
You know what they haven't seen?
- A lime.
- A twisted mango.
- [Director] Do you guys
feel so millennial right now?
- I feel very millennial.
- Considering we just
tried to arrange them
to look nice on Instagram, yes.
- I would drink all of them.
- I would totally do Twisted Mango
with a nice classic vodka on ice.
- Maybe some lemon vodka
to mix with this orange.
- So you're doing more
of a bartender vibe.
I'm just trying to get a little bit drunk.
- This looks, oh the
shadows are very cool.
Okay, one, two.
- We gotta take it in portrait mode.